When we look at the plot, a few things
pop out right away. We can see a nonlinear
relationship. Maybe it's exponential or maybe it's something else.
We can see that the dispersion or variance of
the relationship also increases as carat size increases. With
just a quick look at the data we've learned
two important things about the functional relationship between price
and carat size. We can add a linear trim
line to the plot by using the stat smooth function
with method equals lm. We can see that the linear
trend line doesn't go through the center of the data
at some key places. It misses it here. It should
curve a little bit in the center of the relationship,
and it should slope up more toward the end. And
if we tried to use this to make predictions, we
might be off for some key places inside and outside
of the existing data that we have displayed.